[Música]
el secretario general de la otan jens
stoltenberg pidió a los países de la
alianza atlántica que entreguen a
Ucrania nuevos sistemas de defensa aérea
tras la escalada de la ofensiva rusa
precisamente hoy Rusia volvió a
bombardear las ciudades saprilla
conectaremos con Bruselas
nuevo día de protestas en Irán desatadas
por la muerte de maxa la joven iraní que
murió bajo custodia de la policía de la
moral el 16 de septiembre su caso ha
desencadenado un movimiento masivo
contra el régimen de la República
islámica Tenemos reporte desde Teherán
el sindicato cgt aseguró que llevará
ante los tribunales la medida del
gobierno francés que obliga a los
trabajadores en paro a volver al trabajo
la huelga de los empleados de refinerías
ha generado un gran desbastecimiento de
combustible ampliamos desde París
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relacionada con la guerra en Ucrania en
un Bruselas se celebra la primera
reunión de la otan desde la anexión a
Rusia de los territorios de lugansk
gerson y saporiya en el encuentro el
secretario general de la organización
jeans toltenberg agradeció a los
miembros de la alianza atlántica el
envío de nuevos sistemas de defensa
antiaéreos a kiev ante la escalada de la
ofensiva rusa recordemos que tras la
explosión del sábado en el puente de
crimea de la que Rusia acusa a Ucrania
el lunes las fuerzas de Moscú lanzaron
un ataque masivo con 81 misiles sobre
todo el territorio ucraniano incluida
kiev como resultado al menos 20 personas
murieron y decenas de civiles resultaron
heridos conectamos ahora con nuestra
corresponsal en Bruselas Esther Herrera
Buenos días hacer Cuáles son los
acuerdos entre los miembros de la otan
para reforzar su apoyo a kiev ante el
recrudecimiento de los ataques rusos
Buenos días los ministros de la otan hoy
han querido enviar un mensaje muy claro
van a ayudar a Ucrania pase lo que pase
lo que pase el secretario general de la
otan asegurado que ahora mismo la
prioridad es ayudar a Ucrania con
sistemas de defensa antiaérea algo que
se ha visto muy claramente en estos
últimos ataques por parte de Rusia de
los últimos días en territorio ucraneal
en este sentido stoltenberg ha
agradecido la ayuda de Estados Unidos y
también de Alemania en que se han
enviado este tipo de sistemas de defensa
recientemente De hecho también el
Secretario de Defensa de Estados Unidos
y hoy Austin ha asegurado que este tipo
de ayuda tanto la urgente como la de más
a largo plazo va a seguir enviándose a
Ucrania con toda la ayuda que sea
necesaria justamente hoy además los
ministros de defensa de la otan se han
reunido con su homólogo ucraniano o
Alexis nicof que se ha podido escuchar
de primera mano Cuáles son las
necesidades de Ucrania en materia
militar muchos países en la reunión han
asegurado que ya han anunciado nuevos
compromisos de ayuda militar a Ucrania
por ejemplo Canadá ha anunciado 30
millones de dólares en un nuevo
equipamiento militar pero también Países
Bajos en que seguirá ayudando con
formación y también sistemas de defensa
de cohetes Esther le pido que se quede
con nosotros para continuar analizando
la respuesta de occidente al avance de
esta guerra pero antes veamos Cuáles son
exactamente los equipos de defensa que
solicita Ucrania
armas terroríficas que descienden del
cielo a velocidades Aparentemente
imposibles estos drones suicidas y
misiles de cruceros son disparados en
masa desde barcos y aviones rusos
Moscú ha estado enviando una lluvia de
destrucción sobre Ucrania durante dos
días lo que ha llevado al presidente
bolodimir selenski a pedir ayuda urgente
a los países del g7
les pido que refuercen Nuestro esfuerzo
conjunto para ayudar financieramente
crear un escudo aéreo para Ucrania
Ucrania pretende instalar la llamada
cúpula de hierro similar a los sistemas
de defensa antimisiles que existen en
Israel o alrededor de Washington DC la
capital estadounidense está protegida
por el Sistema Nacional avanzado de
misiles tierra aire o nasams para
Ucrania esta tecnología podría ser un
escudo crucial en 10 segundos el sistema
puede detectar misiles enemigos y
destruirlos en pleno vuelo creando en
efecto una burbuja de protección
el sistema nasams tiene una capacidad de
interceptación de hasta 150 kilómetros
el uso principal de ese sistema Sería
para la defensa de kiev y la defensa de
las principales ciudades en concreto
actualmente no podemos hacer una burbuja
100% impenetrable incluso con muchos
sistemas combinados de múltiples capas
en un solo lugar
el Ministerio de defensa de Ucrania la
mitad de los 84 misiles de crucero rusos
fueron interceptados el lunes como aquí
nos de ucraniano utilizó un misil
disparado desde el hombro con gran
efecto para su defensa antiaérea kiev
despliega actualmente pequeños
lanzadores de misiles portátiles y
sistemas s-300 desarrollados por la
antigua Unión soviética El martes llegó
desde Alemania el primer sistema de
defensa antiaérea Iris más sofisticado
mientras Estados Unidos ha aprobado el
envío de al menos 8 baterías de sus
afamados nasams a Ucrania
y este volvemos con usted para analizar
una Arista clave de esta guerra y es la
crisis energética que enfrenta la Unión
Europea y ante el aumento sin
precedentes del precio de la energía los
27 están intentando encontrar un acuerdo
para regular el mercado eléctrico de
hecho este es el objetivo no de la
reunión en Praga de hoy de los ministros
de energía de la Unión Europea En qué
punto están las conversaciones se espera
un consenso pronto
Sí así es la reunión de ministros de
energía que se ha producido en Praga ya
ha terminado Y aunque no se esperaban
resultados concretos Sobre qué es lo que
se puede hacer para bajar los precios de
la energía Así que ha ayudado a
acercarse a este punto qué es lo que se
puede hacer para poder abaratar los
precios de la electricidad la gran
mayoría de países está a favor de que se
deben abaratar estos precios pero aún no
se han puesto de acuerdo en cómo se
puede hacer aún así la gran mayoría sí
que accede por ejemplo hacer una compra
conjunta de gas entre todos los países Y
así pueda costar mucho menos el gas el
que se importa en este sentido la
comisión europea va a anunciar nuevas
medidas ya la semana que viene Como por
ejemplo esta compra conjunta de gas pero
también una de las mayores discusiones
donde hay menos consenso es en la de
poner un límite en el precio del gas los
líderes tendrán que abordarlo la semana
que viene en una reunión extraordinaria
aquí en Bruselas Ester Muchísimas
gracias Seguiremos muy de cerca a estas
negociaciones
y en otras noticias se detectó una fuga
en el oleoducto subterráneo drusba que
lleva petróleo ruso a Alemania a través
de Polonia según el operador la fuga
está cerca a la ciudad de polock en el
centro de Polonia Por ahora se desconoce
la causa del incidente que ha derramado
400 metros cúbicos de petróleo
y en Irán continúan las protestas
desatadas por la muerte de maxa a mini
bajo custodia policial concretamente de
la policía de la moral la muerte de la
joven de 22 años ha desencadenado un
movimiento masivo contra el régimen de
Teherán previamente hablamos con nuestra
corresponsal Catalina Gómez Ángel sobre
el desarrollo de la situación
por lo que se puede leer en esos
mensajes que circulan en las redes
sociales esta nueva jornada de protestas
un mensaje más al Estado iraní de que
estás movilizaciones no van a parar ya
casi se cumple estamos A pocas horas de
que se cumpla un mes de la detención de
esta joven curda maxa a mi niete eran
por la policía la moral horas después
sería llevada al hospital con muerte
cerebral también una de las razones para
la convocatoria del día de hoy se debe a
la gran represión que estamos viendo en
las últimas horas en el kurdistán iraní
esto viene dándose desde el comienzo de
pocas horas después de la muerte de
maxamney recordemos que ella es kurda
allí empezaron las protestas no
solamente en su ciudad sino en la
capital del kurdistán iraní en San
Andrés Donde ha habido una gran
represión de las autoridades sin embargo
esta se ha aumentado según se ha
conocido y a pesar de las restricciones
de internet en los últimos tres días no
se sabe el número de Muertos pero se
dice que hay bastantes las personas
heridas se habla de Gran presencia de
las autoridades no solamente en San
anddashi sino en maribán una población
fronteriza con el kurdistán iraquí es
que irán acusa a dos grandes grupos
opositores kurdos iraníes con base en
Irak de estar moviendo esas protestas
dentro del país una organización de
Derechos Humanos iraníes que opera en
oslo habla de 201 personas muertas hasta
el momento y dice que muchos de esos
serían en el kurdistán iraní Pero eso
también llegan un momento en el que el
estado el iraní intenta crear lazos o
por unos puentes de comunicación con la
población hoy veíamos Cómo eran está
llena de pancartas con la bandera de
Irán y hablan de la unidad de Irán Y a
ella versiones dentro de algunas
autoridades que hablan de crear diálogos
puntos de encuentro pero hoy el líder
supremo volvía y se refería a estas
protestas como pequeños movimientos
aislados que estaban siendo desde el
extranjero
vamos ahora a Francia porque el
Sindicato de trabajadores cgt afirmó que
impugnará ante los tribunales la
decisión del gobierno de obligar a
trabajadores en huelga a volver a sus
puestos de trabajo en el depósito de la
petrolera Epson Mobile en normandía el
sindicato alega que El Ejecutivo vulnera
así el derecho a la huelga mientras el
gobierno justifica la medida como una
necesidad de restablecer el orden
público para asegurar el suministro de
gasolina tras semanas de escasez causada
por los paros en refinerías tanto de
Epson como de total donde continúan las
huelgas nuestra periodista en París
Erika y la barria Nos daba previamente
los detalles
sí la crisis de los combustibles
continúa en Francia y eso Pese que al
gobierno anunciado Que las próximas
horas va a comenzar la requisición de
una parte de los trabajadores de los
depósitos de combustible de la petrolera
estadounidense eso móvil que tiene en
normandía como ayer lo advirtió la
primera ministra Elizabeth recordemos
que los trabajadores de la petrolera de
Estados Unidos y también de la francesa
total llevan más de 10 días en huelga
pidiendo mejoras salariales lo que
mantiene un tercio del país sin gasolina
hoy el ministro portavoz del gobierno
liberal dijo que la situación debiera ir
normalizándose las próximas horas sin
embargo reconoció también que se está
volviendo insoportable para una parte
importante de los franceses así que por
lo mismo el gobierno no descarta
requisicionar los trabajadores de otro
depósito de combustible esta vez en el
norte del país cerca de dunkerque que es
otra de las regiones afectadas por este
movimiento de huelga en total de siete
refinerías que hay en Francia 6 se
encuentran en huelga y además los
trabajadores del sindicato cgt de 5
reactores nucleares se han puesto
también en huelga en Solidaridad con los
trabajadores de las refinerías por su
parte los directivos de la empresa
francesa total han aceptado reunirse con
Los líderes sindicales de la empresa
total del sindicato cgt hasta ahora se
habían negado si esto no levantaban el
movimiento quizás podría ser un inicio
de solución mientras siguen las colas en
las gasolineras con prioridad para los
médicos los policías y las personas
minusválidas el presidente Manuel macron
será entrevistado además esta noche en
la televisión pública quizás se refiere
a esta crisis
el 12 de octubre de 1492 Cristóbal Colón
llegó a América una llegada que
desencadenó en la colonización española
del continente americano más de 500 años
después la fecha sigue causando
controversia por Cómo debe ser nombrada
o por si directamente debe o no ser
conmemorada Dios Muñoz nos explica
12 de octubre de 1492 el navegador
italiano Cristóbal Colón llega a América
en una misión para la corona española
ese día la historia cambió para siempre
se empieza entonces a hablar de
descubrimiento de América un hallazgo
desmentido por la llegada de otras
expediciones previas y por los múltiples
pueblos originarios que ya habitaban
530 años después el debate no ha
terminado es el 12 de octubre el día de
la raza y de la hispanidad como se le ha
nombrado tradicionalmente o mejor
cambiarle el nombre a día del encuentro
Entre dos mundos como se le llaman chile
el día de la nación pluricultural en
México el día de la de colonización en
Bolivia O como le llaman también en
Estados Unidos desde el año pasado el
día de los pueblos indígenas
pero Estados Unidos todavía celebra
simultáneamente el Día de la Raza
nomenclatura contra la que desde los
años 60 y hasta la actualidad los
movimientos indígenas hacen activismo
para reescribir la historia en la línea
en los últimos años se han derribado y
vandalizado múltiples estatuas de
colonizadores así fue en Colombia
[Aplausos]
Puerto Rico
y hasta en Miami
para el de colonialismo la
reivindicación es cuestionan la
imposición occidental y colonial que ha
vivido América por siglos lo califican
de genocidio por los millones de
indígenas asesinados
mientras que los más puristas consideran
que es un golpe a la memoria histórica y
creen que celebrar la hispanidad es
también celebrar una identidad común
y cerramos con información espacial la
NASA anunció que el 14 de noviembre
volverá a intentar el lanzamiento de la
misión artemis 1 destinada a llenar el
camino para el regreso de la humanidad a
la luna recordemos que la agencia
estadounidense ha tenido que posponer ya
tres veces la partida de la misión dos
veces por razones técnicas y otra por
causas meteorológicas
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en francés 24 y 24.com
[Música]